is that is that what happened with you
in Evander Holyfield you guys are
friends now I think you guys are working
in business yes yes yes yes yes I mean I
always um bust this chapter me and
you're the only people still making
money from a fight that happened 30
years ago straight up right that's right
yeah how did that friendship develop
because at one point you guys were as
competitive enemies as it gets right we
always been I knew him since I was 17
years old you know from the boxing scene
and um
I had made these ears
um when you pull up at your company that
they launched
holy bites yes and um show a picture of
it the product if you can rob my God
Tyson asked you to show a picture buddy
the ear and um
they were going off the hook and he was
a little offended he was a little
offended at first and then he ended up
time why are you doing this to me man
he's a little offended to me so the
profit of it he said I Prophet hey I'm
with you
Mike bites here's like you might have
taken oh you're 30 already
yeah
the only thing guys I can't really ask
you a question what house I um
I'm trying to think the word satanic
people are so happy yeah
yeah we have families we live in a
country of savages you know that right
first of all first time I saw it I'm
like what what should the fight if you
watched them did you watch the fight
live or no live no I mean I wasn't there
but I was seven years old yeah you're
seeing you did like oh you were at the
actual fighter fight yes
me and uh Chuck Zito and Stallone we're
all there that night
what uh what was the reaction how long
did it take for the audience to know
what happened oh it was crazy yeah I I
don't think I didn't know right away
what happened didn't understand it but
then we were hearing things you know
because I wasn't like the third or
fourth row we're hearing things and then
then obviously everybody knew after that
but
yeah what happened afterwards you know I
was with I was with my wife too and the
place went crazy afterwards I told her
we're not leaving here just sit here
until everybody leaves and everything
gets calmed down but that was crazy I
know the word without Mike it's crazy
huh you you said you made 30 million
dollars I think you said this last year
sometime in October you made 30 million
dollars from this fight just from the
bite well after I know I made 27 because
they took three for me
they're finding me three look
they find you for three million for
there you go you said I got fined three
million dollars for that uh yeah and I
might have made 30 million dollars since
that happened from the bite for me yeah
the bite heard around yeah no from Jeff
um the Mike bike every time I'm doing a
signing and they take a picture of
biting people's ears all over the world
take a picture bite in my ear
I got what what the hell things you got
white supremist bite my ear right there
listen No Power Man bite my ears
you've made it if it's that so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]